the United States is falling out of love
with fast food and is now trying to eat
fresh so now fast food corporations are
exporting their empty calories to other
countries Nancy sue nuestro futuro Ori
es el gran vía pradhana big mac ayudar a
la formación professor the pursuit of
the global poor is by design you make
your product ubiquitous you have signs
everywhere you put things on television
the result is big brand food
corporations filling up on profits
meanwhile their newest customers are
getting hooked on high calorie meals and
global obesity rates are rising if
you're interested in changing the food
system or having a healthier food system
the first thing you want to do is
exercise some critical thinking about it
hey guys I'm stream and this Sunday on
aj+ we're talking about the new frontier
of fast food
the United States is fat but it wasn't
always of course you can be large and
healthy but there's a problem when
people are eating high calorie meals
that also don't have enough nutrition
the average u.s. citizen is 23 pounds
heavier than their ideal body weight and
the nation's obesity rate has increased
dramatically in the last three decades
23 percent of adults were obese in the
1980s today that number is closer to a
third and now the nation's waistline is
expanding while the number of fast-food
receipts are shrinking in recent years
fast food sales declined across the u.s.
and while Americans are moving beyond
the drive-through to focus on farm-fresh
food the fast food industry found itself
with a whopper of a problem now it's
scouting new markets to peddle its
product and professor marion Nestle no
relation to the nestle food brand by the
way believes corporations are targeting
the global south the one specific reason
their job is to sell more food they have
stockholders who expect them to increase
their profits every quarter Nestle
PepsiCo and General Mills have been
going hard in developing nations up
pending traditional diets across three
continents they've been driving up
global sales from Latin America Africa
and Asia the ramped up marketing and
infrastructure over the past decade and
guess who they're targeting the new
middle class the very poor desperate to
feed their families and the holy grail
of brand loyalty children let's start
with everyone's favorite sugary beverage
soda the US of A used to be the biggest
market for soft drinks since 2000 sales
have declined so beverage giants like
Coke and Pepsi adapted their marketing
tactics to win over children around the
world the soda companies have said that
they're going to put billions of dollars
into marketing every place that they
possibly can for example they committed
17 billion dollars to marketing in
Africa between 2010 and 2020 so what
does it look like when a food company
spends
millions in advertising in a new market
well Nestle went next level with their
tactics and hired a boat to float down
the Amazon River selling junk food in
remote locations because what locals
really need is Nestle's chocolate
pudding the many companies have poured
into promotions worked sugary drinks
sales doubled in Latin America since
2000 and now the world's biggest soft
drink market is Latin America that's a
problem for dr. Esperanza Cerrone who
resisted the spread of fast food and
fats in Colombia Lomas Guerrero India
es que la Mensa mayoría la población
cinquain Tremmel nutri saya porque este
nos ESO de peso Oh porky AMS bhai pace
is this una Luz blamin mass graves
Cerrone has felt the wrath of the
industry for her efforts but we'll get
more to that later right now we're gonna
talk about how cheap high calorie and
low nutrient food has flooded markets
and created a whole new problem people
who are both overweight and
undernourished it's a problem Brazil is
currently facing traditional diets of
rice beans grilled meats and salad are
being replaced by frozen instant
packaged foods and sodas currently one
at about five people in Brazil are obese
while the rate of overweight people has
almost tripled to 58 percent and this is
in a country where 2.4 million children
are still suffering from malnutrition
public health experts say the rise of
chronic illnesses heart disease and
diabetes is reaching epidemic
proportions across the globe type 2
diabetes is not a disease that anybody
wants to have or that you would want to
wish on anyone it leads to blindness it
leads to foot amputations it's
debilitating Latin America isn't the
only place food companies are targeting
Asia and Africa have seen the wild
expansion of fast-food chains like KFC
McDonald's Pizza Hut and Burger King did
you know there are more KFC's in China
than in the US KFC and its parent
company YUM yeah YUM is actually the
name of the company have more than its
Fried Chicken going for it the brand has
a certain prestige in developing
countries because it's from a rich
country the US KFC already has about 850
locations in South Africa and it takes
banding throughout Ghana Nigeria and
sub-saharan Africa the spread of fast
food is exacerbating the obesity crisis
in Ghana 27 percent of adults are obese
that's nearly the same rate as the u.s.
so how are some of these countries
fighting back
many are curbing the expansion of fast
food through legislating soda taxes on
sugary drinks just like in some American
cities countries like India Saudi Arabia
South Africa and Colombia to name a few
have all implemented soda taxes as a
means to reduce consumption the soft
drink industry spin is that it would
drive up the cost to poor people but the
truth is they're the ones targeting poor
people with their products
remember how Latin America consumes more
sugary drinks in the United States the
fight against soda taxes is heating up
there Sirhan's activists food
organization is no longer allowed to
speak publicly about the health risks of
sugar a government agency slapped them
with a quarter million dollar fine and
shut down their public health ad saying
it was misleading yo stylee who knows
we're done intervene eros Barrios
computadoras de la misma manera y
algunos de nosotros pezzo personalmente
supremo's amenazas in barrio supertunias
en la calle y aunque nadie NOS dijo esto
lo está siendo la industria Quay
simplemente ryouna coincidences clara
y lo que knows aperian ellos que
nosotros ominous Aaron yaki no Scalia
Ramos but other countries governments
have been more supportive in slowing the
spread of these food companies I was
particularly impressed with the soda tax
in Mexico passed over everyone this
prediction and the Chilean front of
package labelled scheme which sets a
model for lots of countries in Latin
America the package label scheme she's
talking about is pretty much what the US
did to fight big tobacco
defendi muscle in questionable
cicadas por que es la mia mas cost
effective aquel recomienda larva nice
SEO mundial de la salud y multiplies
investigación a scientific ascend todo
el mundo para sa stimulate consumer
particular men Tenten los más jóvenes
ENT la polla SEOmoz bola de Lima's bode
so who's actually left to advocate for
healthier options well oftentimes it's
up to public health departments or local
governments to do the work teach people
the sugary beverages are not good for
your health that has worked in the
United States so that's one way to do it
another is to try tax initiatives to try
to get sugary beverages out of schools
workplaces government institutions
hospitals so what's the solution
we've already learned some countries are
taking a stand with policy and education
campaigns and at the same time we're
watching fast food companies creep into
more markets promising finger-lickin
good meals you can have your way but
what is the United States responsibility
in preventing the export of obesity
thanks for watching don't forget to Like
share and subscribe we just spent a ton
of time talking about the global
implications of junk food I don't need a
ton of it because I love to cook but I
do love a good burger let us know in the
comments how much fast food you eat and
what you like us to explore in the next
video